i'm here with my trusty co-pilot rossi
ross matthews and
i am also joined by the co-author of our
mutual cookbook called rebel homemaker
which by the way comes out any second
we're so excited it's friend of the show
drew crew member and extraordinary chef
all right halloween is one of our
favorite times of the year and it's also
the best time to watch horror films we
just did hocus pocus with the girls at a
big thing of popcorn enjoying your
favorite snacks getting creative getting
a little culinary for your fright night
um so rossie yeah and today we've got
some spooktacular halloween movie snacks
and they're all inspired
no one told me that was going to happen
you know how i am with scary movies no
more of that i'm too much
i kind of dig it okay by the way i'm
into it okay
all right well i'm not gonna say scary
movie anymore because every time they
play that scary movie don't stop it
all right
so these are inspired by drew's scary
movie
um all right
well what's first on our menu pilar so
we're gonna kick it off over here with
an icy witch's brew
we've got some dry ice in there as you
can see the smoke ross thank you for
tending to the dry ice i'm into this
it's a hibiscus based punch actually
and we make um frozen eyeballs
they're lychee fruit
do you want to get your hands in color i
do so you're going to take the pitted
lychee fruit oh it's so cold and you're
going to stuff the blueberry into the
cavity just like that like ross is doing
that
and then you're going to dip it in some
red color
i see
you are so funny oh my gosh and then
you're going to freeze them and so they
double up as little ice cubes
in your they're so beautiful they're so
blue look look how good i'm such a good
pupil
all right shall we move on to the next
yes please that's right our next treat
so fun and i'm going to pass it down
actually to you
is um they're extraterrestrial treats
inspired by everyone's favorite
extraterrestrial oh
they're brown butter
puffed rice treats stuffed with
marshmallow and peanut butter
no i mean bye you can't go
the brown butter does it
all right
oh my god wait is that a little barbecue
yes we have a bike and the moon and a
little basket so if you guys want when
you have people over for halloween you
get a little basket a little bike cut
out a little moon
it's so good
all right we're going to move on all
right if we have to
the next treat is inspired i'm going to
swap with you oh yeah the next treat is
inspired by
mr ball eggs i believe drew you coughed
up mr bollocks
it's from santa clarita diet
mr ball eggs over here
is made of um leftover cake
with uh frosting that you smoosh
together roll and then he's dipped in
melted chocolate so we're actually gonna
have you guys roll the cake and you're
gonna roll him in some melted chocolate
exactly yeah you know what and then
you've got to pop them on the side and
then you're going to do the sprinkles
here you go
by the way
i have to say i've i've never seen
sprinkles like this they're like little
gunmetal grapes they're really beautiful
they they feel very baller and aggro and
they're really interesting
yeah like they would have heard it just
eat it
just eat it
such a threat and
the wonderful thing about mr ball legs
too is that he is fully edible so his
legs are made of pretzel sticks
dipped in more chocolate yeah i love
pretzel sticks
so
shall we shall we yeah
[Applause]
is perfect for the energy we're going
for right now i love it
so to your right we actually have a
really beautiful three-tiered red velvet
cake with cream cheese frosting so
you're gonna take the candied glass
shards it's a little bit of sugar water
and a little bit of corn syrup and you
bring it to a boil just like you're
making candy and then you put it on a
prepared baking pan and you allow it to
harden and then you shatter it very
gently yeah
[Applause]
beautiful
[Laughter]
and ross i have some fake blood for you
also oh thank you what do i do with it
do i want to like drip down i think as
much or as little yeah
there you go okay
oh that's good
i love this i have one more surprise for
your
that the sound drawers again because i
can't handle that
so where i'm going to have you guys cut
into the cake just like you would a
normal just cut a slice i'm going to
step back
and joining us and the audience are
actually this feels inappropriate hold
on a second
joining us in the audience are a mom and
daughter who i recently met on instagram
live paulette and harper are here
[Applause]
well we were watching a different movie
we were watching school of rock on the
cbs sunday night movies guess what what
that when i was on the airplane i
watched it
e.t
well this is a perfect question you know
because i'm really interested did you
find it a little scary or were you okay
with it i was okay with it and then
facaded the alien
did you like e.t
the karmic wheel did me such justice by
finding the two of you thank you so much
for picking up my instagram live
invitation you're welcome and paular
apparently there's a surprise inside
this case it's a little surprise so why
don't you and ross go ahead and
cut those
that's hardcore oh yes whenever i try to
like cut a cake for my kids it doesn't
it it's not oh
wow
oh my gosh oh that is so fun
look how cool that
thank you for making halloween so
special for us thank you guys for having
me
[Applause]
for coming up with these amazing recipes
both of you together your collaborations
if this is what they look like i'm in
and you can find all of this on our
website to make it your house on a
spooky movie night and i just want to
thank you so much for choosing to spend
your time with us we make this show for
you that's right harper i'm looking
right at you
so please take this good energy
[Music]